we have a situation earth to the d3
caste do you guys ever take a breather
looking at all your new projects it just
goes to show you guys aren't slowing
down anytime soon
performing in Hairspray live was the
most exhilarating thing I've ever done
in my life ever since descendants three
wrapped you have been spreading
Hollywood glam all over the industry and
we are loving it keep it up you guys we
can't wait to see what you do next these
tendons three is finally out but that
hasn't stopped the cast of the upcoming
Disney Channel original movie from
moving onward and upward here's what the
cast of descendants three is up to now
playing game shows as it turns out the
cast of you students 3 is pretty good at
game shows Kenny Ortega dove Cameron
Sophia Carson booboo Stewart and
Cheyenne Jackson just went toe-to-toe
against the cast of American housewife
on Family Feud the goal was to raise
money for the make-a-wish Foundation by
far the funniest moment was during the
rapid-fire part of the show Steve Harvey
told Sophia to fill in the blank
he said lip blank the whole audience
laughed when Sophia said injections
Steve Harvey said that was the most
Hollywood answer ever
Sarah Jeffery Audrey has got everyone
talking ever since she was confirmed to
be the main villain in descendants 3 I
got to be dangerous but what has Sarah
Jeffrey been up to since she put down
Maleficent sceptre and that's stolen
crown let's just say she's still
involved in magic after d3 sarah has
been working on the TV show charmed as
Maggie the mind reader so this means
I've really was reading minds
additionally according to her IMDB page
she recently starred in the short film
Dahlia it's about an online couple who
meet in person for the first time Sarah
has been able to go from princess to
which while making her way from the
small screen to the big screen Cheyenne
Jackson this blue haired villain had us
all wondering if he was now fat or not
you abandoned me when I was a baby you
know and fans were curious to find out
if he would turn out to be a good guy by
the end of d3 I'm sure you to be very
be together after descendants three
Cheyenne Jackson traded in the blue wig
for a wolf costume that's right Cheyenne
recently starred in Hollywood Bowls into
the woods as Cinderella's Prince aka
the wolf he performed on stage in the
Stephen Sondheim and James Lepine
musical pure loving the wolf look on him
booboo Stewart booboo Stewart has been
one busy dude since d3 wrapped
production to affirm us he has starred
in a string of films and TV shows since
he took off that leather villain KITT
outfit most notably he is playing the
role of Vic Lakota in the upcoming TV
series Paradise City it's about a rock
star who's living the high life and a
young rookie kid who looks up to him
that was all real they would never put
it on they open the series is set to
aired later this year with all of Boo
Boo's Talent it's easy to see why he has
been so busy since dissonance 3 Sophia
Carson ever since those blue locks
cascaded down Sofia's shoulders when she
played the role of Evie in d3 I mean the
four of us are living the dream here and
we finally get to share that Sophia
Carson's career has been on fire most
recently she played the role of Ava in
Pretty Little Liars the perfectionists
when people hear the name Jalali I need
them to think of me she was also the
talk of Hollywood when she walked the
red carpet at the Golden Globes holding
the black times up ribbon in place of a
handbag way to go Sofia currently Sofia
is filming a Netflix dance movie called
feel the beat it's about a young woman
who failed to find success on Broadway
so she returns to her small hometown to
train a group of misfit young dancers
for a big competition after watching her
perform on The Descendants films we know
she won't disappoint when she dances in
her upcoming film Thomas Doherty Thomas
is still hopelessly in love with his d3
co-star dove Cameron but what does he do
when he's not worshiping the ground his
girlfriend walks on quite a lot actually
he's starring in the upcoming movie
high-strung free dance which is set to
come out in October you missed the turn
I don't need to see it again he told
Teen Vogue that he's excited to leave
his boy next door image behind with his
role in the new movie Thomas plays the
role of a dazzling young choreographer
named Xander reigns from the trailer he
seems to be a tough choreographer who
does a lot more ballet than Harry did in
descendants 3 yep he's still dreaming
what exactly is going on between you and
Xander dove Cameron since production
wrapped on descendents three dive
Cameron has been busy on stage rather
than on screen we are all capable of
good she performed on Broadway as Sharon
clueless later she performs in the
London premiere of the light in the
Piazza she also did hairspray live which
is a combination of stage and screen
she told 17 that the experience was
terrifying and exhilarating I think
because of that you just kind of have to
like surrender and be like go for it so
we'll dub be making another appearance
on the small screen rumor has it she may
be moving on to the big screen instead
she could become the next Glinda in the
upcoming movie remake of the Broadway
musical Wicked
she would make an amazing Glinda davon
Thomas Doherty are still together and
blissfully in love dove has also been
working on her music career she just
told the Twitterverse that she's got a
new single coming out very soon this
former villian kid is truly unstoppable
are they still friends according to dub
Cameron the core for co-stars from
dissonance 3 still have an ongoing group
text Duff shared that the usual text is
love you how are we all today and are
you eating it's obvious that ever since
you sentence theory brought the group
together they have been and will
continue to be best friends forever no
matter how much their lives changed
after d3 who is your favorite
descendants character tell us in the
comments don't forget to like this video
and subscribe to the things thanks for
watching we'll see you next time
[Music]